Speaker 1: Let's go to Thomas from the
Bronx. Thomas, welcome to the program.
Speaker 5: It's awesome. Hey, David. How are you?
Speaker 1:
I'm doing well.
Speaker 5: All right, great. Let me just
mute my background. We're training.
I'm supposed to be listening.
Speaker 1: I love it.
Speaker 5: So quick question for you.
And it's probably going to start as a question
and really more turn into a a request to for you
to interview some subject matter experts in this
area. Okay. So person considered myself on the
left. I would love to have a magic wand and make
Bernie Sanders 30 years younger and have passed
all policies to nationalize pharma and energy,
etc., etc.. Right? Yeah. But one of the problems
the world in general, not just the US has, is
really the ever growing population expansion over
the past decades and centuries and finding enough
resources and jobs, etc. to support the ever
growing population. So my question is, if we wave
the magic wand and everything was nationalized and
everything was provided, UBI, etc., would that
tend to lead towards an explosion of expansion
of longer life expectancies with healthier, higher
birthrates of people not having to, for example,
have abortions because they can't afford it? And
would there be playing devil's advocate here,
would there be a negative to having kind of all
these meds and a super healthy population in
regards to expansion of that population?
Speaker 1: So I believe that Arthur C.
Clarke explores this in the novel
Childhood's End. Let me see if I can.
Yes. Arthur C Clarke explores this idea in the
1953 novel Childhood's End, which was turned into
a miniseries. Maybe it was like Netflix or Amazon.
I don't remember. So it's widely explored in
science fiction. The belief generally seems to be
that if those needs were met, the birthrate would
naturally decline. Actually, people would wait
longer and choose to have fewer kids and that over
time it would actually take care of itself. Now,
here's the other issue related to this, Thomas,
which is birth rates are already going down, down,
down to the point where it's believed that Earth's
population is actually going to start declining
after peaking at I forget the exact dates,
but it's going to keep increasing.
Speaker 5: China's worried about that.
Speaker 1: Now. China's expected to see
a population decline from, I think 1.4 to
1.3 by 2050. Yeah. So no, I don't think so.
I think I think people would live better,
longer lives and would have fewer kids and
it would all fall into a new equilibrium.
Speaker 5: Okay, then that wouldn't
be right. Instead, Arthur Klein,
he said that was a science fiction author.
Speaker 1: Childhood's End. Arthur C Clarke,
Excellent novel. I recommend it to you.
Speaker 5: Thomas Edison I'd love to see if you
could interviews with, you know, nonfiction
rights for that kind of talk about this and
see what they think. Because certainly I agree
about the the birth rate thing. But of course,
with advancing technology and energy consumption,
that, you know, the population as a whole is not
going to turn vegan overnight. So the factory
farming would still be an issue. Anyway,
thanks for a thought. All right.
Speaker 1: Thomas from the Bronx
raising a very important issue
to cap off calls for today. I
will take more calls again if I have
anything to say about it. And I hope
to hear from you next time. We'll take a
quick break and be back right after this.